and I gotta call you out on something so
you talk about education system
sometimes I've heard you say a little
broken in high school and so on
I'm not are they calling out I just I
just want to talk about it because I
think it's important and there's
somebody who loves math he talked but
your own journey was school didn't give
you passion value well you could maybe
talk to that but I for me what I always
maybe I'm sick in the head or something
but for me math was exciting the way
martial arts what we're exciting for you
because it was really hard I wanted to
quit and the idea with education I have
that that that seems to be flawed
nowadays a little bit is that we want to
make education easier that we want to
make you know more accessible and so on
accessible of course is great but you
kind of forget in that and that those
are all good goals you forget in that
that it's supposed to be all so hard hmm
and like teachers just the way your
wrestling coach if you like quit you say
I can't do any more I have to come up
with some kind of excuse your wrestling
coach looks at you wants to say get your
ass back on the mat the same way I wish
math teachers did that when people say
it's almost like cool now to to say I
it's not math sucks that's not for me or
science sucks as his bush teacher is
boring I think their dish there's room
for some culture or says no no you're
not if you just put in the time and you
struggle then that opens up the universe
to you like whether you become a Neil
deGrasse Tyson or the next Fields Medal
winner in mathematics I would not argue
with you for one second I would also say
that one of the more beautiful things
about human beings is that we vary so
much and that one person who is just
obsessed with playing the trombone and
to me I don't give a [ __ ] about
trombones but that's okay
like I can't be obsessed about
everything some people love golf and
they just want to play it all day long
I've never played golf a day in my life
set miniature golf and just [ __ ]
around
but that doesn't it's not bad or good
and I think there's there's definitely
some skills that you learn from
mathematics that are hugely significant
if you want to go into type of fields
that you're involved in for me it's
never been appealing but it's not that
it was just difficult it's also that
it's just for whatever reason who I was
at that time in that school with those
teachers having a life experience that I
had that was not what I was drawn to but
I was drawn to his literature I was
drawn to reading I was drawn to stories
I was drawn to possibilities and
creativity I was drawn to all those
things you're an artist of it too yeah
yeah I used to be I used to want to be a
comic book illustrator that was that was
a big thing when I was young I was
really into comic books I was really
into traditional comic books and also a
lot of the horror comics from the 1970s
a black and white like creepy and eerie
did you ever see those things creepy and
eerie like black and white yeah they
were there were a comic book series that
existed like way back in the day was all
they were all horror and they were like
really cool illustrations and these wild
stories but it was comic books but they
were all black and white that's creepy
and eerie that's the actual name yeah
eerie and creepy were the names too like
that was from what year was that
it says September but it doesn't tell
you what year but I used to get these
when I was a little kid man I was like
eight nine years old in the 70s good and
evil yeah it was they were they were my
favorite like that's a cover of them and
like do you have like covers that were
done by like Frank Frazetta Boris
Vallejo and just really cool [ __ ] and I
was fat that was what I loved those when
I was little I was always really into
horror movies and really into like Bram
like look at this werewolf one that was
one of my favorite ones that was a crazy
werewolf that was like all fours who's
the hero usually superheroes everybody
dies in those two that's the beautiful
thing about it everybody
gets [ __ ] over there's nobody that was
the thing that I really liked about them
was like that nobody made it out alive
there was no one guy who figured it out
and rescued the woman and they wrote off
in the sunset uh-uh but if you turn the
corner and they'd be a [ __ ] pack of
wolves with glowing eyes waiting to tear
everybody apart and that'd be the end of
the book and I just I was just really
into the illustrations I found them
fascinating I just I loved those kind of
horror movies and I loved those kinds of
illustris so that's what I wanted to do
when I was young yeah I think the
education system is probably we talked
about creativity it's probably not as
good at inspiring and feeding that
creativity because I think math and
wrestling can be taught systematically I
think creativity is something well
actually I know nothing about it so I
think it's harder to take somebody like
you when you're young and say and
inspire you to pursue that fire whatever
is inside one of the best ways to
inspire people is by giving them giving
them these alternatives that are so
uninteresting like saying you're gonna
get a job selling washing machines you
know like [ __ ] that I'm gonna figure out
a way to not get a job selling washing
machines like some of the best
motivations that I've ever had have been
terrible jobs because you have these
terrible jobs you go okay [ __ ] that I'm
gonna figure out a way to not do this
you know and whether you don't want to
call it a DD or ADHD or whatever it is
it makes kids squirm in class I didn't
squirm in every class I didn't squirm in
science class
I didn't squirm in in you know in
interesting subjects there was things
that were interesting to me that I would
be locked in and completely fascinated
by and there was things where I just
couldn't wait to run out of that room
and I don't know what the reason is but
I do know that a lot of what we call our
education system is engineered for a
very specific result and that result is
you want to get a kid who can sit in
class and learn so that they could sit
in a job and perform and that for
whatever reason that was just I mean I
didn't have the ideal childhood
maybe if I did I would be more inclined
to lean that way but I didn't want to do
anything like that like I couldn't wait
to get the [ __ ] out of school so I did
never have to listen to anybody like
that again and then just a few years
later I mean you graduate from high
school and you're 18 when I was 21 I was
a stand-up comic and I was like I found
it this is it I'm like good I found
there's an actual job that nobody told
me about where you could just make fun
of [ __ ] and people go out and they pay
money to hear you create jokes and
routines and bit